for more on the path of the storm and
how climate change is affecting the
weather yes even when it's cold outside
we're joined by cbs news meteorologist
and climate specialist jeff beridelli
jeff
good morning to you hey good morning
tony good morning everyone we
are sitting and waiting on a blockbuster
snowstorm it is
underway but it's going to get fast and
furious soon here in central park so far
we have around six inches of snow in
total probably 12 to 18 inches but areas
north and west are going to see a lot
more snow
take a look you can see the coastal low
developing convective snow
we may hear some lightning and thunder
out there as those heavy bands begin
to move northward as we head through the
day today the heaviest snow around new
york city long island
into northern new jersey is going to be
during the morning and afternoon hours
and that will spread into new england as
you can see
now along the coast that could mix with
a little bit of sleet and rain which
would limit totals but inland
it is all snow and it's a prolonged
event some places could see 36
inches excuse me 36 hours of snow and
yeah it's possible some places will see
over two feet but i doubt we'll see
three feet of snow but it could happen
in northeastern pennsylvania look at
that bullseye near scranton the poconos
also northern new jersey
that's anywhere from you know 18 plus
inches of snow
to maybe two and a half feet of snow so
there's going to be a lot of heavy snow
especially just northwest
of new york city okay let's talk about
what's happening you know why are we
seeing this extreme weather
across the nation right now well it
started two to three weeks ago with a
sudden stratospheric warming so above
the arctic about a hundred thousand feet
above the arctic
we saw air temperatures warm about 100
degrees
and it all happened within around three
or four days or so
so it warmed up really really quickly
that throws the atmosphere off kilter
in addition because of human caused
climate change the atmosphere in the
arctic is warming three times faster
than the rest of the globe so everything
is discombobulated if you will and what
we end up with is this very blocky
kind of squirrely jet stream almost
looking like a snake
that causes blocks in the atmosphere so
the system in california
got blocked and caused extreme rain and
snow and now this system
is getting blocked here on the eastern
seaboard producing two feet plus of snow
in some areas and also climate change a
warmer atmosphere
means heavier precipitation and so these
blockbuster
snow storms a lot going on in that map
jeff beradelli thank you very much 36
hours of snow for some
folks we ain't seen nothing yet